- “Hey, man. The police got us.
You need to come.”
- [Laughing]
- He said “us”?
- “Us.” I was like, “Hold on, wait.
No. The police got YOU.”
- [Laughing]
- He said, “Nah, I just told ‘em who you were.”
Why would you tell ‘em that?!
♪♪♪
- Darnell Dockett!
- How you doin’, man? Nice to join you, man.
How you doin’?
- Good to see you, man.
Your turn to break ‘em. Go ahead, man,
since you a guest here.
I don’t know when’s the last time you played.
- So, uh, I just wanna let y’all know
I’m good in a lotta things. Pool is not my strength.
So if I, um, don’t make a good hit,
the first ball that pop off the wall,
I’mma hit you in your head with.
OK? So long as we good.
- [Laughing] It’s all good.
- Lemme see if I do this right. Look at that!
- You scratched, but it’s all good. We’ll make it work.
- Scratched on the first one.
- We gonna make it work.
- Man, I told you, man. This is not my strength.
Don’t judge me.
- So in 2008, had a great run with the Cardinals.
Leading up to the NFC Championship Game
against the Eagles, what were you doing that Friday?
- I was livin’ my best life.
- [Laughing]
- I, I mean, it was the first time I’d ever been
to the NFC Championship Game.
Feelin’ good, healthy.
Um...Kurt Warner’s probably readin’ his Bible, goin’ over plays.
Um, Larry probably gettin’ his feet done, you know?
Edgerrin James probably somewhere bettin’ somebody.
And me, I’m on a damn four-wheeler doin’ anything I wanna do.
- All right, you gotta tell me:
What happened there? Tell me the story.
- So me and Antonio Smith was like brothers.
Like, we, like, the, the movie Stepbrothers.
And we did pretty much everything together.
I mean, Tone was like, “You know, let’s go get four-wheelers!”
So I was like, “Bet, come on.” We just go to the shop.
They had two limited-edition four-wheelers.
- So why exactly did you get a four-wheeler?
- It was one of these things where,
when you’re bored and you, you makin’ a lotta money
and you look for things to do in Arizona
because it’s not really a lot to do.
So we get on the four-wheelers. I called him.
I said, “Tone, meet me at the park up the street.
We gonna ride.” He said, “All right, cool.”
So we get on the four-wheelers.
We ride through the neighborhood.
We ride through the parks—kids out at the parks—
all through the streets.
You know, gettin’ ready to play in the NFC Championship Game.
We win, we go to the Super Bowl. We livin’ our best life.
- Mhm.
- Police come.
- Damn.
- I see ‘em, and the first thing I’m thinkin’,
like, “We get in trouble, we done.”
You know what I’m sayin’? And I’m tellin’ him,
so he’s like, “All right, we gonna—I’m, we gonna break.
We not gonna ride together. We gonna break.”
Turn around, come back across the school.
I see two police officers sittin’ at the school with their lights on.
- Oh, man.
- So now I figured, “All right, we in the chase now.”
So I’m goin’ down a road. I’m cuttin’ through the streets.
I’m goin’ through back roads. I get to my house.
I go in the house; I’m panicked. Call Antonio,
I’m tryna just make sure that he didn’t get caught or somethin’.
Fifteen minutes later, my phone ring.
- Tell me what happened when that phone rang.
- Antonio called me. He says, uh, “Hey, Doc!”
I said, “What’s up, man? You good?”
He said, “Hey, man, the police got us. You need to come back.”
- [Laughing]
- He said “us”?
- “Us.” I was like, “Hold on, wait. No.
The police got YOU.”
- [Laughing]
- He said, “Nah, I just told ‘em who you were.”
Why would you tell ‘em that?!
Ohhh, my God. I said, “Tone, why you doin’—”
He said, he said, “Nah, man. They cool.
They just want you to come on back, and
we probably gonna get a court date.”
“We gonna do what? First of all, Tone, I was not there.
I don’t know whatchu talkin’ ‘bout.” I hung up the phone.
Then he calls back again and say, “Yeah, man...
I’mma give ‘em your address so they can just come by.”
I said, “Wooow.”
- Wooow.
- I said, “Tone, you really doin’ that?”
He said, “Nah, man. They cool, they cool.”
I said, “Tone, no. No, they not cool.”
About 10 minutes later, the police call
and was like, uh, “Hey, we
need you to come back around here.”
I said, “For what?”
He said, “Because you was ridin’ another four-wheeler!”
And at this point, I’m, like...I gotta admit to it
because if I don’t, it’s like we lyin’ to ‘em.
That might make the situation worse.
- Yeah.
- So I was like, “All right. I’m, I’mma come over there.”
But I never admit that I was on the four-wheeler.
I said, “Oh, I’ll, I’ll be over there.
I’mma get my suit. Where you located at?”
He said, “At the same park you was doin’ doughnuts in.”
I’m like, “I, I, I don’t know. I’mma ask Tonio.
Tonio, hey, where he even wanna meet at?”
And then he said, “The park.”
So I knew where the park was, obviously.
And I get in the car, man, and it’s, like, seven police officers.
They all sittin’ out there.
I get out, and he was like, um, “Mr. Dockett?”
I was like, “Huh? You talkin’ to me?”
He’s like, “Yeah. Uh, you got any I.D. on you?”
I was like, “Why do I got I.D. on if you already know it’s me?”
And then he said, uh, “What was y’all thinkin’?
Y’all got the biggest game of the year to Arizona.
You know, we need y’all to go to the Super Bowl.
And what was y’all thinkin’?
What if one of y’all fell off these four-wheelers
and we didn’t have you guys?”
And then after that, he was like, “We gonna
let y’all go, but can y’all do us a favor?”
And I’m like, “Oh, God. Like what?”
He’s like, “Just beat the Eagles’ ass for me, OK?”
I was, like—my whole heart just came from my ankles,
went up back up into me. I was back beatin’ again.
And I was like, “Man, I gotchu. I gotchu.”
We obviously played the game.
- Mhm.
- That officer comes to my house on Tuesday,
knocks at the door, and I said, “What’s goin’ on?”
He said, “Thank you for keepin’ your word. Congratulations.”
And I was like, “Man, I, I ain’t ridin’ my four-wheeler.
My four-wheeler put up.” We started laughin’ about it.
And still to this day, me and him still
have a relationship with bein’ cool.
I lied to you the first time. I’m a real professional.
- Oh, is that right?
- We’ll play again. But you just gotta move the balls.
- Once you put money on the line, that’s when it change up?
- Yeah, you just gotta move stuff
a certain—gotta move certain things in my way.
Thanks for kickin' it with us.
Subscribe to B/R to check out
more dope videos like this one.